I'm loving this like American Pie
reunion meat but here's my question do
people still look up to you and say this
one time at Bank yes they do what you
love ly to be associated with the movie
people still know but I have two
daughters now and when they're with me
and they people don't follow through
hang the line I'm like can we just stop
there I'm not I get really panicked well
wait you have kids like wait when it
came out did your kids see him no no my
by my daughter was 12 and so that that's
a little early that's that's a little
early my son was 15 and he was going to
come with us in Los Angeles we went down
for the premiere of the movie and the
night before the premiere he he said he
was on the phone call with his friend
back in Toronto and they said well
what's going on he said well I'm going
to the premiere of American Pie tomorrow
night with my folks and the friend said
oh don't see it with your folk don't see
it with your folk don't want to see this
with your folks so he came to us and
said you know what I think I'm not gonna
go tomorrow and I'll see it when I go
back to Toronto with my friends and I
said I thought oh well okay it's gonna
be a big night meanwhile we went to the
premiere saw the movie I'm so glad he
wasn't
my god is we go back like 17 years you
are at the Idol finale in fact it's
funny because my husband was working on
TV show angel at the time and I loved
angel I loved he was supposed to work
but he happened to be chopping of
chopping cutting flowers but with a
knife which is dumb and he slit his
wrists luckily it was okay he just had
some stitches or whatever but they gave
him the day off and I was like great you
can come to American Idol with me but
when he went to work the next day they
were like you faked an injury just to go
see America we had to show the stitches
but because of that clapping shot we I'm
gonna tell you it's so funny but when I
found this out I was like we didn't
really know that it was that big we were
in a bubble right so we didn't know they
were like there were a lot of
celebrities there like for us I'm from
like a small town in Texas and I was
like who's here and like there are
certain you know we thought it was a
crazy thing it was so weird it was also
there I know I know
yeah we were balling it was
[Applause]
and now I hear also neighbors we both
live near each other why we should
become best friend I am down then you
could we could like borrow sugar yes so
what would I know your house
well you might like because I over
decorate for Halloween and and first you
giant cats in your front yard no oh I do
know that person but know that about me
for Halloween my family we named them
yeah for Halloween I decorated the gate
as as Frankenstein and Bride of
Frankenstein okay I'm gonna go cruising
your neighborhood yeah I do I love
decorating as well you're crafty I hear
as well of crafting yeah like just I
it's my happy space it's fine I get on
music why I'm over forget the sugar okay
forget it
come let's fast yes and you know my
daughter's probably almost old enough to
like babysit your kids see in it like
you know I'll let her watch them we have
a guest house that I've taken over and
turned into the crafts house I did that
two hours for a minute and then I had no
days off and thus I was like well this
is useless but but I did that with ours
too yeah and I says no loses it no it's
smart because then it like keeps guests
away yeah well or you go to break tell
us about this series outmatched that's
what your ass so um Jason Biggs has a
new show is a very large community um
and Eddie Kaye Thomas and I are gonna be
on Jason's show so it really is
everything
it's about Jason plays a part of a
parent duo that has like I think on the
show yet um for kids and what like most
of them are genius ISM one isn't but
they're just like trying to keep up with
how smart their children are oh my god
and then the one kid is like you know
just I'm creating you know subscribe to
my channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel please don't make me keep going